نعم نبدا من مدينه رفح حيث غاره جويه
اسرائيليه قبل قليل طالت ارضا بالقرب من
الحدود مع مصر في محور صلاح الدين تحديدا
ودو انفجار كبير في عقاب هذه الغاره التي
تعتبر الرابعه من نوعها في غدون ساعات في
هذه المنطقه وايضا سبق هذه الغارات قصف
منزل بالقرب من معبر رفح البري ادت هذه
الغاره ايضا الى استشهاد امراه فلسطينيه
وطفلها ونقلت عديد من الاصابات ايضا الى
مشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف النجار شرقي مدينه
رفح هذا المشفى الذي استقبل على الاقل
سبعه من الشهداء في نهار يوم امس اربعه
منهم ج قصف مركبه مدنيه في منطقه ميراج
شمالي مدينه رفح وثلاثه منهم جرى انتشالهم
جراء قصف اسرائيلي غربي مدينه خان يونس
جنوبي قطاع غزه بكل تاكيد بدنا نلاحظ ان
العديد من الشهداء والجرحى يتم نقلهم
واجلاء المصابين الى مشافي مدينه رفح في
الاسابيع الاخيره بفعل العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائ المنطقه الغربيه لخان يونس التي
ادت الى قطع التواصل مع المشافي الرئيسه
المحاصره مشفى الامل ومجمع ناصر الطبي
الذان يشهدان مح في محيطهما عمليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه طالت الاحياء الملاصقه لهذه
المشافي وسط قصف عنيف وايضا اعاقه عمل
مركبات الاسعاف الفلسطينيه في التواصل حتى
والاتصال والوصول وال العمل على نقل هؤلاء
وانقاذ حياتهم وبالتالي هناك عشرات من
الشهداء مازالوا في الطرقات وايضا جرح
ينزفون في منازل محاصره في منازل عفوا
محاصره في المناطق الغربيه والغربيه
الشماليه كان في ساعات النهار هناك تراجعا
تكتيكيا لبعض الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه من المنطقه الغربيه لخان يونس
بعدما اقامت حاجزا عسكريا بالقرب من جامعه
الاقصم هذه الاليات بعد التراجع توجهت
ربما الى عمق او حاورت تعميق العمليه
العسكريه في احياء جديده في مخيم خان يونس
ومنطقه حي الامل وسط اشتبكات عنيفه وقصف
مدفعي ارتفعت هذه الوتيره في الساعات
الاخيره من المساء يوم امس وفجر هذا اليوم
وتسمع اصوات انفجارات كبيره كذلك اطلاق
للنيران كتاب القسام قالت بانهم استهدفت
عدد من الاليات العسكريه كذلك سراء القدس
وكتائب شهداء الاقصى في بيانات منفصله
قالت بان مقاتليها ياخذون اشتباكات عنيفه
كانت هناك ايضا غاره بالقرب من مدرسه
قنديله التي تاوي عشرات الاف النازحين في
مخيم خان يونس ادت الى سقوط شهيد وعدد من
المصابين وايضا شهيد طفل كان في غاره على
منطقه بلوك جي في مخيم خان يونس وتم ايضا
نقل شهيد ثالث من المنطقه الغربيه لخان
يونس اجمالي عدد الشهداء في الساعات
الاخيره في خان تجاوز ال 18 شهيدا تقريبا
سبعه منهم في مفى الامل ثلاثه في مجمع
ناصر الطبي واربعه كانوا في المشفى
الاوروبي واربعه اخرين تم نقلهم الى مشفى
الشهيد ابو يوسف النجار في مدينه رفح كذلك
كانت هناك غرات جويه في المناطق الشرقيه
لخان يونس والمناطق الغربيه والمناطق
الجنوبيه في منطقه بطن السمين ومنطقه الحي
النمساوي وايضا شضايا وصلت الى ثنائي مجمع
ناصر ال